from outside the Big Brother house with
Brent I'm Julie Chen Moonves good night
Julie Chen making a subtle statement
with her on air sign-off on Thursday
nights a live episode of Big Brother
it's the first time she's ever used her
husband les moonves's name on-air double
eviction night this was Julie's return
to TV after taking a few days off in the
wake of her husband stepping down as
chairman and CEO of CBS it's a promise
she made to fans with this statement on
Sunday quote I am taking a few days off
from the talk be with my family I will
be back soon and we'll see you Thursday
night on Big Brother prior to taping the
show the 48 year old television show
host gave another subtle nod to her
husband with this pick her wedding band
on full display as you will know
Dooley's husband is in the news and
she's taking off time to be with her
family it's very embarrassing and
upsetting to have to talk about her
husband but we do we feel it's right
Julie has yet to return to her hosting
duties on the talk
[Applause]
you